[Music]
what's up oh hi Matt hi have you ever
seen the room fuck no good to know
okay how have you been
tired how are you tired but enjoying
life yeah good I recently watched a
movie called 1408 yeah so do I oh okay I
see you only I see him right here yeah
it's a complete coincidence actually
that everything's eventual book which
contains that short story is just
sitting right there yeah that's a pretty
good short story yeah I also put the
blu-ray there out of complete
coincidence as well complete coincidence
cool do you want to talk about it maybe
I'll do it alright cool 14:08 is
directed by mikael håfström based off of
the Stephen King short story of same
title and stars John Cusack and samuel l
jackson John Cusack plays Mike Enslin a
paranormal D bunker of sorts he goes to
hotel rooms or places that are
supposedly haunted and writes novels
about them and you can tell that he at
maybe one point in time had a little
faith maybe in this but has since lost
that faith and no longer believes and
kind of spends his time proving to
people that these things don't really
exist Samuel Jackson and John Cusack and
I moved together that was good yeah
they just flat-out bring it if Cusack
and Sam Jackson mail it in Louie sucks
mm-hmm but they provide authenticity for
the audience was a short story from
Stephen King did you read that yes I did
how'd you like that right the short
story starts with Mike Enslin arriving
at the Dolphin Hotel like that's the
opening there is no past there's no
surfing scene there's nothing it's just
he's at the hotel he's there to stay at
the famed 1408 room for a night and half
of the short story is actually the
meeting scene
between Samuel Jackson and John Cusack I
felt like when I read it it's almost
like the old Daniel thing and I finally
got to get the room stuff which is
really cool like the short stories are
great it does some things better than
the film actor like the film Asli
obviously does things better than the
short story like flushing out the whole
experience something that was really
great for the short story was the
madness he even fucking entered the room
yet because the door is all like going
yeah talking well I really really love
the playing off of the cardiac arrest
thing in the short story I like just the
length of it it was a little bit more
stretched out compared to the film and I
really like just the whole building up
of the mystique of this room compared to
the film so even King did a great job he
did yeah he actually listed this as one
of his favorite adaptations he loved
this movie and he understands that when
you have a short story and it's supposed
to be like this one singular creepy
moment that you're going to have to put
some more meat on the bones of that and
we're going to get into some spoilers
here if you've never seen 1408 the movie
largely deals with grease and what
someone goes through when you lose
someone he lost his daughter in the past
a very young age to illness and so it
sort of falls in line with the fact that
he is just trudging through this job he
has as a writer there's a fan who comes
to one of his book signings with his
older book that he wrote that was a very
personal story that meant something to
him
he has since got away from that and now
just writes about how much ghosts
probably don't exist and it's this
really great way of building his
character you see that he is like this
weird guy who is catering to a crowd of
people who want to know about the
paranormal and with his new novel days
writing but at the book signing he's
like basically telling everyone that
it's bullshit
and there's like four people there who
want to meet him and that's it yeah I
thought that was kind of funny it's a
great way to build his character you
talked about how he's weird we were
texting each other while watching the
movie like John Cusack is great so you
want to talk about how funny he was my
favorite two lines are
the one book clerk he's like whispering
and he's signing like hey I want to see
a guaranteed ghost we're going to go it
goes guaranteed Orlando haunted mansion
it took me a full second to be like wait
what did he just say do you really just
say that only shit that's funny yeah and
the second one is careful to go No thank
you I don't smoke
oh this yeah that's in case nuclear war
breaks out I gave it up a long time ago
it's part habit part superstition
you know writer thing you do drink don't
you of course I just said I was a writer
but it is really funny in this movie and
one of my favorite moments in the movie
it's this little moment in the elevator
between Olin and end 'ln your usual
young maid from El Salvador found
ourselves locked to the bathrooms only
there for a few moments but when we
pulled her out she's dead no blind she
taking a pair of scissors and gouge
their eyes huh he's laughing a stir
yes sir Cusack basically has to sell the
entire film alone he's in this room and
it's just the magnetism of his
performance and I think he did a great
job the great thing about this movie is
it's literally him it's this room for
like 90% of film and it's so riveting
going back all the way back to your
first bit of that monologue was we watch
the commentary and that first scene with
him with the bed and breakfast the
earlier draft before these two guys came
on to rewrite it
there was actually going to be a false
scare like I forget what it was like
some kind of like dead baby but like I
think the people run the bed and
breakfast were faking it I like I'm glad
I didn't do that because it shows that
this guy has been put up with a bunch of
shit that's been faked or he hasn't seen
anything because he's not believer yeah
any writes about it in the commentary
that writers were talking about how they
appreciated the first drafts but they
didn't want that false scare there
because that sort of puts the audience
in this position where what they're
seeing isn't real
yeah and so they never a lie to us like
when shit gets real in 1408 the room
it's all really happening yeah that's
great this film it's a great back and
forth drama you have these things going
on to him and then there's a lot of say
spoilers get false ending and that's my
favorite false ending probably maybe
besides like alien or something when you
know the this is for the director's cut
which is signed note really weird this
blu-ray is director's cut only so if you
bought this blu-ray there's no there's
three different endings which we can
talk about but this the director's cut
got all the extended footage for the
most part and that you're going to see
the director's cut ending even though
apparently the director doesn't like the
ending strange how that's just like the
most readily available cut there is no
theatrical blu-ray it's weird because I
think the DVD had theatrical cut and
maybe the alternate endings
[Music]
okay lasts more than it out various the
end this film if you're expecting like
to see a bunch of apparitions and shit
you're not going to get that
satisfaction here is really smart it's
kind of like the babadook you might see
some stuff but it's actually like
there's some really deep shit here yeah
and if you go into expecting like to see
like a conjuring and I could be
satisfied but if you want to see like a
baba de perros smart type of thriller
this is your movie right here if you go
into 1408 the film thinking that it's
about a haunted hotel room yes you're
going to be disappointed because it's
about a haunted man yes you know that's
really what it's about this past life
that he has been dealing with where his
daughter died at such a young age him
and his wife going through problems
his dad apparently hates him and doesn't
think that he's a good writer dad's in a
nursing home and when you go into this
room it just takes all of your most
horrific things that could ever happen
to you and puts that in front of you it
makes you relive it it's not like ghosts
are popping out of him that happens a
few times yeah get your your normal
horror movie stuff yeah there's an
amazing doppelganger scene where he died
and he sees like a reflection of himself
they do these things it was like a
tribute to the Marx Brothers this old
Marx Brothers routine that's one of my
favorite scares in the movie too when he
turns around that crazy guy there a
woman I don't know there's like what a
nice or something yeah it's funny
because in the commentary there was a
shitty girl yeah I thought it was to buy
furnaces like this former like mixed
martial arts is like fucking badass
I think he's actually Q sex like
personal trainer they easy to do because
I thousand chick too yeah but it's like
the claw hammer
mecan't manniac or something the
official title but I think my favorite
like scare or sequences I always look
forward to when I watch this movie is
him going out the window
and like hugging the wall and then
seeing that because he wants to get in
the other room but there's no window
there's like some great shit yeah and in
a strange way that's almost like a
little homage to a Stephen King story
called the ledge that's in an anthology
movie called cat's eye that had Drew
Barrymore in the 80s where this guy is
forced on a bet to traverse a ledge all
the way around the building and despite
the extra things like the surfing the
daughter backstory and all that kind of
stuff that's included in this movie it's
actually very faithful to the short
story there's a lot of things that are
direct quotes the phone saying things
like this is five this is eight in the
book this is 6 this is 6 when he is
Fanning through öhlins folder and you
see that text my brother was eaten by
wolves on the Connecticut Turnpike it's
such a weird fucking creepy accent I
know in the short story it's the last
intelligible thing that Mike said into
his recorder yeah the world story having
that just in the notepad and having it
be something it's a quick insert shot
that you read well it kind of recreated
the creepy sense of reading it in the
book too and it's such a weird ass
sentence and it works a lot in the movie
something that's actually not
technically in the book is in this movie
as well because if you read in this King
has an introduction to the 1408 short
story and he talks about what inspired
him to write it and in his introduction
he's like hotel rooms are naturally
creepy yes aren't they yeah I mean how
many people have slept in that bed
before how many of them were sick yeah
hotel rooms are naturally creepy please
don't you think
we how many people sleep in that bed
before you how many of them were sick
how many of them lost their minds before
I came here also I saw one of his films
is really good it's called evil I think
it's like Ostrom something Swedish I
really liked it I really like this one
but I think evils better really I've
never seen it I think his style is like
because I just saw baby driver baby it's
like kind of Spielberg and Edgar Wright
had a baby it's but it's kind of simple
but it's very you know camera moving
also so overall I enjoyed the direction
here a couple nitpicks but what do you
think I think it's really strong my only
issue real issue with this movie is the
Edit I can understand that they have a
hard time with the fact that it's really
just one guy in a room they only have a
lot of people to cut to they don't have
a lot of actors to cut - it's just
Cusack in a room there's a lot of cool
things to do with the room but sometimes
it can be a little rapid-fire the
editing and sometimes early on the
editing of the dialogue can be slightly
unnatural there's one specific scene at
the book signing where the
back-and-forth between himself and his
fans just doesn't flow properly any
questions where's the scariest place
you've ever been scariest place I've
ever been
never heard that question before that's
a joke well all these places have very
colorful histories I would say if I had
to pick a top one I would say Bar Harbor
decided a grisly McTeague wedding night
murder is such an intense place or maybe
st. Cloud Minnesota where the crazed war
Widow to her baby down a well we knows
all have a lotta
I mean it's thick there's thick what
about poltergeists look I'm a good
researcher and it's because it's edited
so rapidly it's almost like they just
really wanted to get to the room as
quick as possible and then there are
moments in the room where you can feel
like it's a series of creepy events that
just keep unfolding without a whole lot
of narrative structure like one crazy
thing will happen and then you're just
thrown right into the next one like when
the TV comes on and for the first time
you see a
home movie of his daughter yeah as soon
as it shuts off he basically turns like
this and sees the creepy ghosts walking
out the window which by the way I love
what they did with these ghosts they
didn't just make him like weird
apparitions they made them really sad
and haunted and they made them look
black and white almost like old film
yeah which was really different and I
had never seen that before but that's
really my only major issue with the
movie is the Edit can be a little rapid
yeah I've noticed that same exact thing
in the beginning I think it was for the
better breakfast stuff and I think just
the edge a little jarring but the rest
of that I was okay the only things I had
a couple mythix were like there's a
flashback with the arguing with the wife
and he's like screaming and yelling he's
being very angry and then the next
sentence was literally I'm a little good
a cigarette it was like really cheery
yeah it was fast I like what wait you
were just like literally screaming and
now your uncle Gesserit like and that's
what I'm talking about that unnatural
dialogue flow yeah sometimes occurs in
the edit do you know what I think we
should have done more we did everything
all I did we should have helped her
fight oh my god if they're telling her
head full of these stories about heavens
in a cloud and she lights up gonna get
their cigarettes okay the sequence
towards the end when he thinks he's out
I think maybe goes on for five more
minutes and should before the great bit
where the post office workers for 1408
are ripping a wall away and you realize
oh my god I'm still in this fucking room
I love that bit yeah so great I think I
like everything in this except the
ending I like the ending which one we
can talk about that right now
yes so this is the director's cut it's
the ending with Sam Jackson getting the
closure I think you get three different
endings so Sam Jackson gets the closure
in this one he's the guy with the tape
recorder and plays it here's the little
girls voice the other one was at the
edge of boot cut which will the one
we're of used to yeah probably the best
Cusick that's the one of director likes
a lot so Cusack gets the clothes or the
wife's in a different room and he hears
the voice and then and he's of course a
lie and I like this the other one is
alternate number one on this blue race
also number two is it theatrical and
this one's a director's so ultimate
number
one is with Tony Shalhoub yeah he gets
the closure he doesn't have the tape
recorder here the voice I really like
this ending he gets the manuscript that
was written in the false ending me too
and the way it's edited together and the
office is empty as the director pulls
the camera all the way back and the
doors closed and it's really creepy and
the line that the dad says it's a
callback to before as for shattering his
death and that's my favorite ending I
really like that one the fact the idea
that the book was written and somehow
has been put into the actual world yes I
really like that idea what comes before
that and yeah yeah I can be like talking
to her in an office I could have had I
can agree at that I did think if they
somehow like could somehow mash up the
free to make like the ideal ending
that's also an issue is that they really
couldn't figure out how to end this
movie yeah there's a lot of theories
about this movie and what it really
means the symbolism behind it who sent
the postcard that kind of thing what or
who is Olin you know is he the devil is
he like a gatekeeper to Hell or whatever
the way that I sort of view his
experience in the room is probably
likened through Dante's Inferno which is
mentioned in this movie when he's in the
cold part like the freezing cold part
he's like I'm in I'm in this circle
what's a circle of Mayan right now and
he's thinking about Dante's Inferno and
there's the parts where it's really
burning hot there's parts where it's
really burning cold then he goes through
grief and all kinds of things and
there's also this theory that's
developed about the stages of grief the
five stages of grief oh you're in denial
and your eventual acceptance of it that
he goes through all stages of grief as
well throughout this his experience in
the room so in a strange way it's almost
like despite how terrible his experience
is for him it's cathartic as well yeah
because he's working through his major
life issues in this room yeah so it's
kind of beautiful actually yeah I think
I for my theory for who's not the
postcard thing is mr. Olin I don't think
mr. Owens the devil you could probably
think that because there's alternate
footage
that when he or when the workers are
tearing down the post office and he's
watching it and I like there's mr. Olin
randomly as like a apparition or
something like I can see why people
think is a double but I don't think he
really I think the actual person I think
it's the final shot of the elevator
doors closing on him when they close on
his head he just has this look like he
knows something that he didn't say I
don't think he's the devil necessarily I
think he's probably just a really
concerned guy yeah there's just some
there's a look in his eye that seems to
sell there's more there than you would
okay so two things I want remember so
the first thing will be of Sam Jackson I
think they said it in interviews or
something but in the short story it's a
like a maybe British place plumpie short
guy's name alcohol in that room you're
gonna have that guy or are you going to
have Sam Jack and say don't go in that
fucking ring okay yeah what's when are
you going to be like oh shit I shouldn't
go in that room it's Sam Jackson exactly
so I'm being but um the second thing
would be I think Olin sent the postcard
so maybe he is the double as like a
metaphor for getting Mike in the room
but who else would have sent it and also
all three endings have Olin Jackson
pretty much like saying there so the
theatrical and the alternate that he's
got a drink in his hand he's in the
office well dumbest and say exactly
after the rooms destroyed so it's more
clear in the director's cut where he has
the box of shit for the wife he's all
like a static he's all like tap he's
like the room is fine you understand the
room is finally closed down it was
almost like it was meant to be he tried
to get Mike in he knew Michaels gonna be
adamant and I got the room shut down
yeah so the directors cuts more clear
the theatrical is a little more washed
out which is what most people saw
obviously when the theories were
developed truly like the people who went
see the movie that saw the edge go like
Louise Olin you go into the director's
cut oh it's okay he's a manager he's not
he's not this or that the bill okay but
it's funny to hear people who have seen
different cuts because there's less sure
there's different cut but there's some
people just have the DVD some people
just have the blu-ray and that's to
follow the studio for not just releasing
a definitive
cut yeah hey it's on for date yeah 4k
give something hopefully yeah
speaking of olan he shows up at one
point in the room as a little man in the
minibar and it might be my favorite
moment ever delivered by a Cusack in a
movie he it's like every bit of this
movie has been building to him
completely losing his shit like he's he
gets really nervous a lot and very
anxious and he's constantly on edge once
things really start happening but it's
all building to that moment where he's
just he's losing it how many experience
have you broken what do you want cookies
huh what do you want from me I walk my
drag that is like top five movie
freak-outs well yeah that doesn't like
better than anything that ghost cage has
ever done like in today so great because
the moon it's actually warranted yes I'm
not laughing at it yeah it's warranted
yeah it's a great buildup of writing and
directing and like I said ties back to
the beginning when I said if he mails
that shit in this movie is like nothing
ah
exactly right right right there is a
nitpick I commonly hear about this movie
from people and that's that olan says
electronics do not work in this room yet
he uses his laptop so like the best way
that I can think to describe that beyond
the fact that it could have been an
oversight is that either the room wants
him to use the laptop to get the wife to
come to the room because at one point
the laptop if the room like takes it
over and presents a fake version of Mike
to get his wife to come there yeah so
that's kind of the way I think it is
like it's not that the it's like this
plot hole the room I think is basically
it allows things to happen the room is
this entity that allows whatever
to happen and if the laptop working at
that moment is what it wants that's
going to happen yeah I agree hard times
with you I don't agree with that
criticism the only nitpick so to have
his technical stuff like you said and
which ending do I want that's not a
problem Sam to stuff definitely my
favorite scene in the movie and I don't
know about you is probably the scene
between Jackson and Cusack that long
scene where they are going over the
motions it's this great power struggle
because he comes in there and he's like
look I'm going to the room I got the law
on my side you can't tell me I can't
stay in this hotel room it's vacant like
you got to give it to me and then all
it's like no I'm going to bribe you with
this amazing drink you're going to look
at all of these pictures and it's also
exceptionally acted between the two and
they're just two playing back and forth
so well and that's one of the things
that works so well about once you get to
the room is the setup is so good that
when he opens the door and it's just
like a normal room and the first actual
scare that happens is the toilet paper
and the chocolates yeah you're like oh
shit like you're that for some reason
was really amazing because they set it
up so well they did it wasn't just like
you know the window coming down on his
hand or the crazy person with a hammer
or they see an apparition right away yet
it was like oh shit the chocolates are
back and then he go he goes kind of
crazy he's like did he toast me did he
did he did he poison this drink and then
he starts like sipping it and he's he's
talking to the recorder so much and you
really get the sense of who he is with
no one else in this room and that's
really good writing and acting yeah this
film does a couple great moments there's
a one I remember in particular about the
direction like he's doing something he's
like very paranoid and there's like a
double snap zoom of it yes that was
great
another thing is like this is a hook
it's fucking awesome there's a vent and
like he has like a newspaper or
something he like kind of hits it and he
kind of looks up he looks around his
eyes dart and it hits it again dude
again the scariest stuff about it has
nothing to do with ghosts or demons or
anything or the fact even that the room
is evil its lines like when he sees his
dad in the nursing home and his dad says
I was
[Music]
you're looking at your future this
crippled old man that's going to be you
one day and it just sends chills down
your spine when you think about that and
that's the best type of King
storytelling right there it's when he's
able to tap into that primal fear that
we have most of us aren't afraid of
ghosts a lot of us are afraid of dying I
think all alone in the nursing home yeah
you know like that's the creepy shit
that this movie explores like the really
dark underlying griefs that you can have
as a person I think it's gravity it's a
great movie I love it I think it's great
it's a very smart psychological thriller
might be one of my favorites and I will
classify this as torture porn very not
like over-the-top soft shit
but like mentally psychological torture
porn I'm going to get 1408 and a -
that's a pretty good score I'm gonna
give this addition the director's cut an
eight because of some technical stuff
and I really like the ultimate number
one ending with Tony Shalhoub in the
main scope that one get the nine from me
okay thank you very much for joining me
in this review Matz I appreciate it
please do check out matched channel it
is in the description below and as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get second eyes oh my god
well I'm gonna go get sued or something
oh yeah let's go eat ha come on let's go
oh yeah you're gonna come over just haha
what a story Matt it's kind of late so
I'm Elsa will be open but so you want to
get food with me in a minute bitch well
I think about getting McDonald's
I hate the doors locked
[Music]
sighs five everyone you've all you know
where Chris went we have Chris here he
will be watching Dragonball Evolution
for the rest of his life
we have a similar fate in store for you
[Music]
no I'm not watching a little no no no no
okay Oh No
[Applause]
[Music]